Whether they're from low budget action
flicks or hated adaptations of beloved
shows and games, these martial arts
sequences leave a lot to be desired.
"The Karate Kid" is one of the most well-known
martial arts franchises in the entire world,
starting in 1984 with the film starring
Pat Morita and Ralph Macchio. The combat
style of karate became incredibly popular
in Western countries due to its depiction
in "The Karate Kid," making it one of the most
influential martial arts films outside of Asia.
That legacy weighed heavily on "The Next
Karate Kid," which was released in 1994.
This time around, Ralph Macchio was replaced
by Hilary Swank in her breakout role as Julie,
becoming the newest pupil of Mr. Miyagi. Despite
praise for the film's lead performances, its
action sequences pale in comparison to the first
three films — as seen in its climactic showdown.
After Julie's love interest Eric is ambushed
by fraternity brothers, Julie challenges
their leader, Ned, to a fight. Even though the
whole thing is scored to epic orchestra music,
Julie takes Ned down without much trouble at
all. His only retaliation is to throw mud in
Julie's face to blind her, which lets him easily
throw her to the ground. Overall, this fight lacks
the clever choreography and stakes that made
"The Karate Kid" a pop culture phenomenon.
"Julie-san, how many times
Miyagi say… fighting not good."
Martial arts films tend to be underwhelming
when they feature non-actors in their lead
roles. That was the first mistake of the
1985 film "Gymkata," which was directed
by Robert Clouse and stars Olympic gymnast
Kurt Thomas. Thomas plays Jonathan Cabot,
a man selected by the American government
to enter an international athletic
competition where the winner receives
whatever wish their heart desires.
"Gymkata" has gathered a cult following
since its release, despite being listed
by Maxim as one of the worst movies ever made.
The fictional martial art that the film is named
after is even sillier than its name suggests,
chaining together plenty of unnecessary flips
and ludicrous jump-kicks. Nowhere is this
goofiness more evident than in the scene
in which Jonathan is ambushed by terrorists,
as the mob of goons are more than willing to
let him set up his attacks with big acrobatic
flourishes. They don't put up much of a fight,
either: once they're hit, these guys are
staying down. and when they're hit once,
they stay down. Combining gymnastics with karate
may not be the best idea for self-defense in
the real world, and it doesn't seem to have
been the best choice for the movies, either.
Hong Kong native Godfrey Ho directed over a
hundred movies that are often regarded as the
best of the worst, with titles like "Ninja:
Silent Assassin" and "Robo Vampire." His
1993 effort "Undefeatable" stars Cynthia
Rothrock as Kristi, a street fighter on
the trail of the serial killer Stingray, and
it's full of Ho's trademark no-budget charm.
After Kristi teams up with Detective Nick
DiMarco, the two track down the killer and
beat him to death in a warehouse. Even though this
climactic fight sequence is satisfyingly gruesome,
much of it involves slow-motion punches
that weren't edited in post-production — the
actors just are just pretending like they're
kids on the playground. Nick and Stingray also
lose their shirts for no apparent reason
other than to show off, and both make the
most of every labored groan. Thanks to its poor
quality, the final fight garnered attention for
the film — and it was eventually featured on
an episode of the show "World's Dumbest..."
"Undefeatable" was elevated from a forgettable
B-movie to a viral cult classic. It may not be
the best martial arts film out there, but
it's certainly one of the most memorable.
"We'll keep an eye out for you, Stingray."
"Yeah, see ya."
Not to be confused with "Miami Vice" or "The
French Connection," 1987's "Miami Connection"
has a reputation for being hilariously awful.
This low-budget attempt at a martial arts flick
was written, directed, and produced by Y.K. Kim,
who also stars as a member of a band of Taekwondo
practicing orphans. When a motorcycle
gang of ninjas kidnaps the lead singer,
it's up to the others to rescue their
friend and bring the band back together.
Kim produced the film independently,
casting his Taekwondo students and hoping
that the finished product would interest a
distributor. Kim later recounted to CNN —
"I showed ['Miami Connection'] to
hundreds of different studios and
distribution companies [...] They all said,
'This is trash. Don't waste your time.'"
In one scene, the heroes are confronted by
the train tracks and take out the members
of the gang all on their own. This would be
much more impressive if most of the thugs
weren't just standing around, waiting
for their turn to battle one on one.
The one saving grace of this scene is the
epic '80s synth music that plays over it.
The Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles were
iconic staples of 1980s pop culture,
originating in comic books before making the
leap to Saturday morning cartoons in 1987.
The heroes in a half-shell became icons
on TV screens around the world thanks
to memorable characters and
entertaining animated fights.
When the turtles were adapted into
live-action, the action choreography
had to get more creative — they were being
played by human stunt performers in suits,
after all. While the first film, released
in 1990, was a box office success,
there were diminishing returns by the time the
third installment rolled around. The third film,
which was released in 1993, underwhelmed fans and
critics. The threequel, also known as "Turtles in
Time," saw Michaelangelo, Leonardo, Donatello,
and Raphael transported back to feudal Japan.
One notably unimpressive fight sequence depicts
the reptilian quartet being attacked by a group
of samurai. The fight proceeds awkwardly, with
the four turtles separated as they each deal with
their equal share of adversaries. Sound effects
and cutesy catchphrases aside, this fight is
missing the stakes and interesting choreography
that the TMNT are typically known for.
"Come on, Jack! It's hammer time! Heheh."
"Mortal Kombat" was one of the most influential
video games of the 1990s thanks to its memorable
characters and over-the-top violence. The
success of "Mortal Kombat" at arcades and
on home consoles quickly sparked interest in
a Hollywood adaptation, which arrived in 1995.
The first "Mortal Kombat" movie was
followed up two years later with a sequel,
"Mortal Kombat Annihilation." While the
first film wasn't a critical darling,
it was praised for its entertaining action
sequences — which is not something the second
film could boast. "Mortal Kombat Annihilation"
was a failure critically and commercially,
with fights that New York Times critic Lawrence
Van Gelder called, quote, "deadly dull."
The film doesn't even do justice to
the franchise's most iconic characters,
Scorpion and Sub-Zero. Complete with stiff
actors and lackluster visual effects,
this climactic battle is the ultimate showcase
of why translating video games to movies was
looked down upon for so long. Another "Mortal
Kombat" film didn't come until 2021, which
mostly restored the credibility of the
franchise's martial arts choreography.
"The Matrix" was released in 1999 and redefined
action film choreography for decades to come,
combining the Wachowskis' love for martial arts
films with science fiction and anime. This success
resulted in two sequels shortly after: "The
Matrix Reloaded" and "The Matrix Revolutions."
"The Matrix Reloaded" was liked by
many, but is typically considered
to be a major step down from the first
film. One of its most iconic scenes,
known as the "Burly Brawl," finds Neo ambushed
by endless hordes of Agent Smith clones — the
perfect opportunity for the directors to showcase
their leveled-up choreography. Unfortunately,
the scene's visual effects put a damper on the
potential for a well-choreographed fight sequence,
as most of the scene plays out like a
video game cutscene from the early 2000s.
Agent Smith clones are tossed around, with Neo's
plot armor being shown off as he's swarmed by
assailants who barely lay a finger on him. Aside
from a few well-framed shots, the bulk of the
scene is a barrage of CGI and fast-paced action
that lacks the first film's extravagant detail.
"It was Smith."
"Yes."
"Now there's more than one of him."
"A lot more."
Much like "Mortal Kombat," "Street Fighter" is one
of the most iconic game franchises of all time,
with the expert kicker Chun-Li being a
series staple since 1991. There was a
lot of pressure to get the action right
when Capcom co-produced "Street Fighter:
The Legend of Chun-Li" in 2009, starring
Kristin Kreuk as the titular martial artist.
In typical fashion for video game movies,
"Street Fighter: The Legend of Chun-Li" was a
critical disappointment. While Kreuk's Chun-Li
never dons her iconic costume, another iconic
"Street Fighter" character does: the Spanish ninja
Vega. Chun-Li and Vega face off during the film,
in a sequence that ideally should pay tribute to
the best parts of the "Street Fighter" franchise.
To make a long story short, it doesn't. The scene
is set at night, making the characters hard to see
and their movements even harder to track. What it
does get right about "Street Fighter" matches is
that the two characters also spend most of
the match not actually hitting each other.
Calling "Dragonball Evolution" a martial
arts film is an insult to fans of both
"Dragon Ball" and martial arts films.
Greenlit during the 2007 writers' strike,
fans were skeptical of Hollywood's ability to
capture the action sequences from the manga and
anime franchise in real life — and as it
turns out, they were right to be worried.
Despite some major deviations from the source
material, "Evolution" at least manages to harken
back to the origins of "Dragon Ball" when Justin
Chatwin's Goku appears in his iconic outfit to
face off against King Piccolo. Terrible
special effects aside, this martial arts
sequence doesn't have half the excitement of
any fight scene in "Dragon Ball Z." Instead,
the two spend most of the fight trying and
failing to hit each other with energy blasts.
It doesn't get any better when they finally
do make contact and fly into the sky via
unimpressive wire work. They awkwardly cling
to each other as they trade punches — and for
most of the rest of the scene, the two
of them rarely occupy the same shot.
When it comes to terrible martial arts films,
the undisputed king is Steven Seagal. Throughout
the 1990s, the action star gained a reputation for
his arrogant behavior off-screen — and ever since,
his appearances have been mostly limited to
direct-to-video releases. One such role was
in Tan Bing's "China Salesman," a Chinese film
in which Seagal seems woefully out of place.
"Hey, why don't you guys speak English?"
After a fight breaks out in a tavern,
Seagal finds himself in a battle with
none other than heavyweight boxing
champion Mike Tyson. This clash of
titans was made to feel like the showdown
of the century — yet it unsurprisingly
features not a single moment of
good acting from anybody involved.
Simply put, showdown of the century it is
not. The two end up moving so lethargically
that it feels like they're in slow motion.
Tyson spends a significant amount of time
breaking things with his fists, while
Seagal, in dramatic, actual slow-mo,
slaps Tyson in the ear. It's a fun bit
of irony, considering Tyson's history
with ears — but it's not enough to make this
fight feel like anything more than a joke.
M. Night Shyamalan has directed some
stellar films, including "The Sixth
Sense," "Unbreakable," and "Split."
However, his creative slump in the
late 2000s included his greatest failure:
the 2010 live-action adaptation of "Avatar:
The Last Airbender." Shyamalan's version of
what's considered to be one of the greatest
animated series of all time has since become
regarded as one of the worst films ever made.
Many scenes throughout Shyamalan's "The Last
Airbender" showcase its lack of regard for
the animated series' action choreography,
but none more so than one notably awful
confrontation between Aang and Zuko.
It starts with Zuko somehow failing
to notice Aang standing right behind him,
and it only gets more ludicrous as it goes.
The fight scene that follows features plenty
more awkward moments between the two — the
worst of which being when Zuko picks Aang up
like a baby, giving the Avatar the opportunity
to wrap his legs around the firebender and flip
him to the ground. Aside from that, it's mostly
attacks that are so obviously telegraphed
you could see them coming from a mile away.
Bruce Lee was a legendary figure whose
influence extends well past the world
of martial arts and into pop culture as a
whole. Lee's career included iconic films
that showed off his talents like "Fist
of Fury" and "Enter the Dragon" — and
his untimely death in 1973 left a massive
void that producers were eager to fill.
The desire for more Lee led to the creation of the
Bruceploitation genre, in which lookalike actors
would take on the role of the beloved fighter.
One particularly bizarre Bruceploitation flick,
called "The Dragon Lives Again," came out four
years after Lee's death, and stars Bruce Leung
Siu-Lung as a version of the star who wakes up
in Hell. During his time in the underworld, Lee
fights several other movie icons including James
Bond, Clint Eastwood, and even Count Dracula.
One of the more unbelievable — and unimpressive
— fight scenes in the film features Popeye the
sailor man, who helps take down some mummies
after devouring a can of spinach. Actor Eric
Tsang tries to replicate Popeye's cartoonish
combat style, but many of the mummies he's
up against barely move at all. On top of
that, it rarely looks like any of Popeye's
punches are actually making contact. This is one
crossover event that's probably worth skipping.